qu'est ce que l'oreille absolue ça c'est
la grosse question l'aurait absolue
c'est une faculté du cerveau a tout
simplement donné un nom à des notes donc
assez rapidement dès qu'on est enfant on
entend une note est automatiquement le
son vient avec
comment sait qu'on a un arrêt absolu
c'est très simple si vous entendez
n'importe quoi dans la rue une
fourchette qui grincent à une certaine
hauteur un taxi les ambulances les
voitures de police et que vous entendez
une note la fin domi si on entend une
série de sons et que ça nous inspire pas
grand chose c'est qu'on a pas l'oreille
absolue
moi je sais que je n'ai pas l'oreille
absolue je l' ai travaillé et j'ai une
oreille harmonique
il ya plein de types d'oreille mais le
grand mythe de l'oreille absolue
justement et cette facilité cette
faculté à pouvoir attribuer un son le
nom d'une note de ring face au lido à
une hauteur mais on peut vivre sans et
on peut même faire de très belles cases
de musiciens sans avoir l'oreille
absolue
[Musique]
on